We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P, uh, we, uh, one of the frequent David
Pakman show bingo terms that some people pay
attention to is related to me mentioning that
I worked at circuit city when I was in high
school and college and the egg man claims
to have won a Sir David Pakman show Bingo
on the basis of me recently mentioning Circuit
City on the bonus show.
Take a listen
Bingo cards and you put down a day would say,
we'll have to delete this.
I will edit this out every time Dave says,
right.
Well, one of the things that my Bingo card
was circuit city or when I worked at circuit
city and I've been waiting for another one
and those ever since then you just hit me.
So I just got big enough.
Oh, Dave Salo brother.
I love you.
Yeah.
You know, I actually don't think I mentioned
circuit city that often.
Most people still, when I look at comments
are very surprised that, uh, I ever worked
at circuit city, but I did and I was in the
president's club.
I was one of the top salespeople at circuit
city, and I got a free trip to Orlando, Florida.
That's right.
It's actually a true story.
Uh, it wasn't the best trip, I will admit.
Uh, but it was a trip.
Nonetheless.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
a new report related to urban congestion pricing.
It turns out that people who live in cities
that implement congestion pricing don't like
it, but then they get over it very quickly
and it actually does help deal with congestion.
We will also talk about a Texas bartender
who has been charged for serving a gunman
before that gunman went on a mass shooting.
And it is a very interesting case from a legal
perspective.
We'll also just talk about the kind of common
sense, uh, elements of it.
And, uh, in Rhode Island students who, oh,
lunch money, we'll get only jelly sandwiches
until their debt is paid.
We will talk about that new policy and much
more get instantly
access, not delayed access.
Instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member@davidpatflynndotcomslashmembershiporbybecomingapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Packard.